let's move on to the campaign the david
pakman show indiegogo campaign at david
pakman.com slash donate had the offer of
a four thousand dollar matching donation
which ran from last Tuesday to last
friday at midnight we came very close to
that full four thousand dollar match
3532 dollars were raised during those
three full days we will soon see the
matching donation for 3532 dollars come
in also very exciting I know Pat and Pat
not so much but Rachel more very excited
by what I'm about to tell you the
previous high water mark for a single
donation was Joshua at four hundred
ninety nine dollars and I am now very
pleased to tell you that during this
matching funds period we saw two new
donations at five hundred dollars each
one from Sarah one from Nick besting the
previous high of four hundred ninety
nine dollars so now 500 is a new high
watermark um I don't I mean I don't know
what we can say I guess what we can say
is can anybody do 50 150 one would be
the next new high water mark for a
single donation the last day of this
campaign which is to increase
progressive engagement and coordination
we are going to be uh having a
professional set designer redesigned
studio we are going to be launching the
david pakman show on amazon prime and
all of these types of things to take a
phrase out of arnold schwarzenegger is
phrasebook uh the campaign ends midnight
the day that Donald Trump is inaugurated
i anticipate emotional distress for a
lot of people on that day Rachel I of
your anticipating the say I am I think
there's going to be an outpouring of
donations due to this very very
frightening day that's impending david
pakman.com slash donate whether you can
donate a dollar or set a new high
donation watermark with a 501 dollar
donation david pakman.com slash donate
is the place to do it